when you want to explore your your your
your sexuality or who you really are and
on the inside you're in a demon
basically or an inner love peace like
what you're gonna do is just really just
just think about it and it really
analyze the whole thing and it won't
anyway will it will come out or anyway
it will it will bring it to a different
level of dark pleasure like good
pleasure
all right bright so bright were you from
version where'd you're up there Jersey
powders of New Jersey yes and tell me
about your childhood yet both your
parents
yes I do help both my parents how was
your childhood my childhood was was was
like a bubble kid and I we we played
outside after school you know salt ball
kickball stickball tree tag man uh all
the good stuff before the streetlights
came on you know any any craziness in
your childhood oh yeah I was molested by
my brother man I remember the whole life
growing up you know there brennick yes
you know it was kind of rough for me at
first when I finally got older and I
realized that it came back to me and I
was like what am I like am i gay like
bisexual whatever I like am I gonna be a
serial killer like from the guys no
criminal mine or I'm Harmonie champa
Lester so I had to dig deep and find who
I really was
so I experiment it kind of finding out
enough I'm not fully gay but I'm
bisexual
so he's late I like girls boring guys
but it's because she wants him out
really late so he's like I'm I don't
prefer but I like the pleasure you know
something I'll share with the world a
little bit so what do you what do you do
for a living I'm a full-time barber we
cut hair for like 29 years
I've traveled cutting here and I've also
like to mess around with like cars and
some stuff like there's a little bit
Canon where bodywork really ok
and so you like to come down here and
pick up some of the girls on the street
I definitely like to come figgle down
some of the girls whether whether they
they're called prostitutes or
substitutes or whatever the case may be
but they're beautiful to me beautiful
yeah so my girls are actually really
nice yeah they're really nice man you
know they just just messed up the way
other people treat them like you know
it's because they are when they are
doesn't really know the Treena like
there's you got to flip it around a
little bit you know different than what
the average person was you know because
it's rough it's rough than they went
that's terrible Rob yeah I mean a lot of
the girls have told me stories about
getting raped and beaten yeah bad
gardens and knives and all kinds of bad
bad oh love me man I'm more of a lover
and a fighter well I like to love man
you know some people just some females
don't know what that really means like
all they did but then it got so abused
that it's like now I was like it's hard
for them to trust and to love I'm hoping
that I could switch all that around you
know so I don't know
are there certain girls that you
frequent more often hello black girls
you like I love my beautiful black
Queens man Salma pretty I'm Spanish I'm
Colombia but Latinas I love my Latinas
long every wrong but a black girls oh oh
and did you ever play around some of the
white girls you're a lot of works ah I
have another chance yet oh but I've
missed the round in Jersey with a couple
white girls all over the world Canada I
mean is this you know really Oh judge
and I'll discriminate but at the same
time is like it's just science how about
the black of Barrett of better than
juice that's something I look around
yeah right they say once you go black
you never go back which is kind of true
and did the cops ever give you a hard
time
Oh one time I got called in Jersey
picking on one it was the most
embarrassing thing in the world
well you don't it happens he got over it
was this dismissed case but you go
through it I have to go through it and
embarrass me when I put my family
through was even worse well it's okay so
uh so you're married or single I'm
single single dad see you ever done that
evil daughter's gonna be 15 in April
okay and are you very beautiful I raised
all the ways she was the 11 years old
and all and all while the public wasn't
working a Warren and I will go to a
barber shop and he has the door you know
so basically she knows who her father is
you know anybody could be a dad she's a
little bit mad at me right now but
she'll realize it later on
Wow why I did what I had to do leave I
was with my vows with the mother of my
child 15 years 15 years and you prefer
the relationships you have with these
women the freedom that it provides yeah
because I don't really have to like I
don't know buddy you know you know you
know you know pay them to stand your
panels to leave and there's not that I'm
having sex with all of them all the time
sometimes I just you know enjoy the
company you know
you know sometimes you know you never
know why God puts or who God puts in
your life to change somebody else's life
you know it takes my life is bit like
things like a perfect stranger to make
me to look at things differently
in our life and that's just you know the
spontaneous things that happen in my
life yeah but all I trust females of all
the guys so it was like I rather or
happy were like four or five females in
one night
that would be you just were hanging out
with the guy it's cool but it's not
really that I'm a horny [ __ ] so
it's like I have to have sex all the
time so it would where do you take them
you think the hotel or to attend hotels
wherever they want to go sometimes
outside I'll pick him sound like I'll
bring [ __ ] home actually and try to find
out their fantasies and accompany to
their fantasies you know but sometimes
you're doing the car yeah I'll take them
to a park and using condoms oh yeah all
the time
I'll stay with a couple your [ __ ]
Robert rubber rubber rubber that's the
damn girls you got to protect themselves
to a man
no no safe safe safe safe safe safe and
then what about drugs the drugs are part
of the picture
yeah I do crystal meth but what is
crystal meth different it's like an
aphrodisiac to me
it puts it fits good crystal Bethenny if
it just starts feeling like pepper loop
yeo-eun after many years the careers
they believe you but yes it's more of an
aphrodisiac to me it's a stimulated like
a Red Bull times 10 you know I don't
start tripping I'm right you know cuz I
do drugs I don't let it do me so I'm
still responsible a little work is your
job yeah I love well I love to hustle I
love hustle also is what I love doesn't
doesn't affect me not actually keeps me
awake because I barely I barely sleep
and when I do it sleepy out doing it
over half and I wake right out like yeah
I'm ready to go
oh one thing that Skid Row has taught me
is you know being mature my name's Lee
you never know I like I learned the law
from beer but short a lot to the people
here are just like so awesome people
you're awesome business there's so much
you mean here at the same time but but
not anybody gives welcome here like you
know you have to really put in your time
to really get accepted you know oh good
people down here beautiful women it's
nice I like the culture here you know I
have this big good to me around I'm
blessed to be here and then it gets an
all different with different parts of
the world as I go along you know it's
also you know nothing I think my
barbershop to a big level that we all
could just get together and just
collaborate and just have a blast some
type of like Freaknik or like a summer
jam or like you know
pip pip pip up parties or something you
know something like that in kids would
be all I know is that I would like to
tell Barbra Q's parties and have
everybody come they're all welcome do
you know why did you find you're happier
as a man who has his choice of all these
different women rather than being
married to one woman and I'm faithful if
I was dead without really I do want to
find the girl of my life because once I
start building his dynasty in his empire
I don't want to do about myself so I
think like I said you know a partner
next to Rita so we can rejoin together
why don't I have a female book as a
right now I found my body worthy enough
full of my time but I don't I don't play
well nobody's heart either so I think I
know how I treat them well you know I
try to be polite full and respectful
because it doesn't exist my voice is to
use my cliche love like for people like
to not like give a comment instead
they're like downgrading I don't
downgrade women when I pick them up I
never Grayson numbers everybody know the
sex that you have with them is it
phenomenal but you're doing everything
pretty well it depends depends a lot
with yeah because I prefer up before the
head without being so I was like you
know I'm just a laid-back guy I think it
comes to me with your problem or they
can talk about whatever they want
you know at that movie but then when
they go out step outside my door
they're on they're over and this is
hopefully when they whenever I go to a
happy place they think about me that's
the impression I have on them yeah it
sounds like you're giving them a nice
break from with her yeah sometimes I
don't even have sex with them it's just
yeah talk what's up girl
depends on her spiritual vibe the vibe
that we get it's some girl that I just
see I try to find a beauty and the most
ugliest day but there's just some people
that are key to the core and I still try
to make them smile you know my little
corny jokes or whatever the case may be
but it's hard they'll give it a venturi
yeah they don't know I don't know what
it is to be loved you know I don't know
what it is to be loved either but I'm
looking for it well I'll try to find out
what it is to be loved you know you
never know how my merrier pours though
oh my Mary a prostitute from the streets
who cares I don't judge there's only
words they hear really just lately all
right well Brian thank you so much for
talking laughs creation yeah thank you
it's on thank you for being so open and
honest hey Ron that's all I know oh
thanks
you